[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
really excited to be talking about
biology talking about arachnology we
have dr. Lauren Esposito joining us hi
thanks for coming out of the show yeah
my pleasure really appreciated it was so
fun when we met as TEDx speakers in San
Francisco and I was like okay yeah she's
really cool we definitely got to get her
on the show yes yes because you had an
actual like scorpion during your talk
you were holding it and teaching about
it and it was a baby it was like a baby
yeah this is a grown adult but it was
really tiny and so there's all these
different insects that exist that are
need to be classified especially spiders
arachnids spiders scorpions and their
kin and how do we hunt down the
unclassified ones and classify them
there's a good question like how do you
know what you know though yeah and
that's what you get to study well I
guess I study all like various aspects
of arachnid biology but I would say
really that's my that's like my baby
that's the thing that I love doing more
than anything is just figuring out
what's out there that we haven't figured
out was out there yet
yes yeah the unknown unknowns now all
right before we get into all the nuance
and there's I'm super excited on packet
tell us about you how did you end up
figuring out that this was what she
cared about I always think of it as kind
of like a series of mistakes that ended
serendipitously I you know actually I
was born into into a biology family and
my parents are both biologists so maybe
it was kind of predestined that I'd
become a biologist of some sort but I
hadn't really thought about what kind of
biologist I just knew what I would
didn't want to do
and I didn't want to be a veterinarian
which is what my father was because I
couldn't like stand the idea of having
to like put animals to sleep it was too
intense for me and but I loved nature
and one of my favorite things to do is
like a pretty young child was to go out
into my parents garden and let flip over
all the pavers yeah
because underneath all the papers was
like earwigs and Rolie polies and
cockroaches and so I'd like flip over
all the pavers and move all the bricks
and like you know totally disrupted her
garden but I was looking for insects and
and in the early years I would bring
them into my mom like alive in my hands
but you probably mostly I grew up in the
urban setting and like a lot of
cockroaches and my mom I would say she
wasn't like in like thrilled about
bringing like her three-year-old
daughter bringing life cockroaches
inside so she taught me how to make
what's called an entomology it's called
a killing jar and basically what that is
is a jar like a empty peanut butter jar
and in at like in a mature kind of way
all you have to do is take a cotton ball
and dip it in fingernail polish remover
and throw it in the jar and it creates
like like a euthanasia gas that human
leaves insects and since my mom was a
biologist she knew this so she taught me
how to euthanize the insects so that I
could bring them inside rather than
bringing them inside alive and that was
kind of like my earliest insect
collection and I would love to say that
like from there I just like continued
with my dream of becoming an
entomologist but really actually I
forgot like I grew up and became a
teenager and was like hated everything
and forgot that I loved insects and just
like Splore in the world around me was
that when you were 10 when you were four
bringing them in no I was like three
years three yeah I was like a tiny kid
whoa like I would keep them in a like an
egg carton I would put like an insect in
neutral
like you know they got thrown away at
some point but what an interesting thing
though that you can use them humanely by
putting a nail polish combo inside
that's a good thing for kids to know
what they want to go in it's a lot
better doesn't keep like torturing them
to a slow death in a jar like just
humanely euthanize them
you can also euthanize them by putting
them in a freezer oh yeah that's right
you freeze them and then vertebra you
can now get like $50 one thousand time
microscopes that are digital and you can
go and start looking at them yeah things
don't like to cooperate when they're
alive yeah which is unfortunate for my
job but but you know
it was so it was really helpful that I
learned how to do that at a young age
and like I had a little microscope that
I would look at things under and yeah I
was really into tide pooling and stuff I
know what so then it was until like
college when I when I started to
rediscover my love for things
tiny because you went for biology yeah
University of Texas El Paso is a
university in my hometown and I I was
originally pre-med as a major because I
thought like oh I like biology and I
want to like have a job so I should go
to medical school because that was like
the only things I know of that you could
do as a biologist was become a doctor
become a dentist or become a
veterinarian and I was pretty sure I
didn't want to do any of those yes look
at how much more we were just talking
about this on the way in there's so much
opportunity that kids children may not
be aware of that exists in the field of
biology
well how ironic like my both my parents
were biologists my mom was not with my
mom as a wildlife biologist so I knew
there were other career options but like
still even didn't consider that I could
do those careers yeah we need more and
this is part of the science
communication thing that we'll talk
about it's just that we need more role
models communicating to children saying
that hey you can be a wildlife biologist
you can be an entomologist I think
there's all these things that we may not
have had the right role models
introducing the young people so
so then okay so biology at El Paso and
then and then you know so then about
like my junior year of college so I
started college I was a pre-med major
and I was minoring in business I was
like I'm gonna do this all the way like
I'm gonna go to medical school with a
business like minor and know how to run
a business when I get out and I was like
man what am i doing this this is not
where I'm supposed to be I was like
sitting in a counting class and being
like yeah this is what I'm interested in
and then I took this class called field
biology nice and basically what it was
it was like a one-credit class so like
kind of like an elective and basically
what it was is you came up with a
research project and then you went to
the field as a class for one week and
you did the project that you came up
with and then you came back and wrote up
the results and the project I came up
with we went the place we were going was
this Beach area in northern Baja
California on the Sonoran desert side so
like mainland Mexico but the north of
the Sea of Cortez and we were in this
intertidal zone that's the largest one
of the largest intertidal zones in the
world so like the difference between
where high tide is and low tide is is
like like hundreds of yards and so
there's lots of things that you can look
at because there's things that like to
live in that intertidal zone a couple
hundred yard yeah I go tide whoa yeah so
like at low tide there's like hundreds
of yards of Beach opposed
oh that might be our UPS package we have
a package so they just leave my little
front of the house and don't tell me
it's like always a mystery if I really
got something or like disappeared
because somebody stole it yeah this is
the how this why door men or women have
become so popular nowadays because
packages and that's what's up with the
doorbell like I have
yeah we have a call box how come you
don't bring it yeah boom we got the
package all right we are back at it so
now the high tide low tide different
yeah that's crazy so with a couple
hundred yards what are - what are you
typically finding there's all kinds of
really cool stuff that live in that zone
and like some of the things that you see
here are things that you might see in a
tide pool so like brittle stars see
stars sand dollars but the thing that I
could the project that I came up with
that I wanted to go and do was to study
fiddler crabs you know the little ones
with a really big hand and they're one
of the things that lives at that
intertidal zone right and my I came up
with this brilliant project I had to do
the literature review so I had to like
go into the library and look up like all
the studies that have been done on
fiddler crabs and the project I came up
with was to dig up fiddler crabs
actually just dig up a beach like sand
these like holes down in the sand and
what I was doing was going out onto the
beach digging up a metre square a metre
cube so like one meter by one meter by
one meter of sand onto a tarp and then
like picking out all the fiddler crabs
and counting how many of them had a big
right hand and how many of them had a
big left hand interesting because it
turned out nobody had ever studied that
nobody had ever done any kind of
scientific study to see whether there's
like a predominant handedness in fiddler
crabs predominant handedness in fiddler
crabs yeah what a dissertation so that
was like my first undergraduate was like
a real scientific design how does one
even know like where do you go into
research like how how would I know where
to look to figure out if that studies
been done yet or not yeah I mean you
know now it's like so much easier than
it was back then like then I went to the
library and like looked up and like the
Dewey Decimal Catalog there was any
journal articles but no it's an access
scientific journals most people can do
it just by going to Google Scholar
search yeah just like you look up
fiddler crab yeah and Google Scholar is
like just like it looks like normal
Google but it just searches within
science of big literature and you can
look up like fiddler crab you could
first figure out like the scientific
name
fiddler crabs which is why oh I don't
know I can't remember looks like you so
now was there a dominant hand in this
and why do Union well it turned out that
it was pretty patchy so like some
patches of the beach like so certain
stretches of the beach had predominantly
right hands and other patches of the
beach head predominantly left hands and
I don't know why I've never done a
follow-up study I probably should and
it's a one predominant hand the other
ones not yes largely basically like one
of them gets knocked off and as the crab
is developing so it's a little crab one
of them gets knocked off and whichever
one gets knocked off regrows is a large
hand whoa I wonder if this images
sometimes it's weird because when you
look at these you wonder if it's
actually it's actually yeah it's huge
like they look like that this weird
gimpy baby hand and I'm like a giant
this and they're using those hands to
like trying to entice females so the
females have two more medium-sized hands
interests the males have like a tiny
ridiculous and other super big
ridiculous in that is a that's a that's
a that's a signal for breeding for me
yeah basically what it is is it's like
allowing the females to evaluate the
strength strength relative strength
because they have to carry this like
massive thing around so they must have a
lot of like caloric energy available to
them in order to like maintain this
massive thing that they're carrying
around now okay now how did it go from
that project to right so I'll preface by
saying that that is not an arachnid
right yeah so there was like a few steps
in between my fingers and my arachnids
yes and the next thing that that I the
next class I took was entomology so I
was like kind of like tightening in on
the things that I was interested in and
that class was great I like made a bug
collection but this time for reals not
in little egg cups in my parents
backyard and so that entomology class
made me start looking at summer
internship opportunities and I found one
that the advertisement was artists rip
on evolution and I was like oh I like
arthropods like crabs and insects so
arthropod evolution sounds like really
interesting
and it was at the American Museum of
Natural History it was a paid internship
nice and I like seven years for quite a
while this was back when I was an
undergrad and I applied and I got it and
I went and that's in New York I was like
New York City it was quiet it was like
you know I was like in the big city
but did you ever do snow before that
snow sometimes Texas in spite of popular
perception okay but it was also the
summer so I didn't see snow not six
months of freezing cold temperatures
though no yeah and I got to New York and
I didn't know who I would was gonna be
or interning with but ended up interning
with their curator of arachnology this
guy named Lorenzo Brendan Lauren Lorenzo
Lorenzo supreme Dini
Lorenzo Prandini is he's a South African
scorpion biologist who had just been
hired as a curator of arachnology at the
American Museum of Natural History and I
worked with him all summer actually he
left for most of the summer so I worked
with him at the beginning in the end and
discovered that I liked scorpions like
they were pretty alright I wasn't like
committed but I was like they're pretty
all right yeah yeah and you were keeping
your options open yeah and and I spent
the summer like extracting DNA from
scorpions in a molecular lab in a
genetics lab and looking at the
collection of scorpions that the
American Museum in had they see we were
learning about how to classify them
based on their DNA both based on their
DNA and I was working in the collection
with actual specimens or any how to
classify them and and curate them like
what being a curator means yeah what
that process consists of like ensuring
and you know what being a curator is we
can talk about a little bit more later
but but at the time what I was doing is
I was pulling scorpions out of like
actually five gallon buckets that had
just arrived to the museum whoa they
were huge like huge amounts of scorpions
and dead scorpions
yeah out of 5-gallon buckets they've
been dead a long time by the time I ever
saw
and I was looking at the labels that
were attached to each scorpion and
recording that information in the
database that we could use to make maps
of where they were distributed because
for most corporations we don't have
things like distribution maps yeah you
know like have you ever opened a book
like a birding book and there's like a
map of where you can see this bird yeah
we don't have that for scorpions because
a lot of scorpions we only know from a
couple of individuals we don't really
know where the species occur so they're
sending you a five-gallon bucket from a
specific geographical area yeah so in
this case what had happened is they'd
received a donation of a another
collection that somebody had the sky
he'd spent his whole life collecting
scorpions and he donated his whole
collection of the American Museum and it
showed up in five-gallon buckets and it
was my job over the summer to secure
eight those specimens and and put them
into the proper jars and make sure their
information was recorded and all that
kind of stuff and so then did you how
did you figure out that okay fine I'll
I'll do well I still still I was like I
don't know like if I'm not committed to
this but I started thinking about what I
was gonna do for my page well not even
there yet I started thinking about what
to do next and I was like okay I've
decided I don't want to go to medical
school what do I want to do and I was
like a PhD like then I don't have to get
a job I can miss good like continue
studying yeah yeah I mean it is like a
job it's it's worse than a job it's like
a ter a week job but I could continue
studying and learning and that's what I
really wanted to do so I applied to PhD
programs City of City University of New
York yeah that was one of the ones I
applied to and because Lorenzo said to
me hey as part of my position here at
the American Museum I'm also faculty at
the City University of New York so you
could come and do a PhD with me if you
wanted and I said you know that's not
the worst idea and well now like 16
years later Here I am I say so now as
you go and start doing the PhD at City
University of New York now you start
slowly falling in love more and more
and what was your dissertation on yeah I
mean I think you know I just like
started learning all this information
about scorpions that made me realize
that that they're a great model system
let's understand many of the basic
tenants of biology things like evolution
they're they're one of the oldest
predators that that ever came onto land
from the sea this is like 300 million
five hundred million like 450 yeah
million years ago they came out on the
land from the ocean most things at that
time lived in the ocean yes definitely
most things with an exoskeleton like so
there were a few worms and some funghi
and some kind of like proto plants not
real plants yeah that were that were on
land but in terms of all the things with
an exoskeleton it was all in the ocean
yep and scorpions were coming up onto
land and and it's been hypothesized that
one of the things that they were doing
in those early days was they were
actually amphibious so they were mostly
living in the ocean but they were coming
out onto land so get to like snatch
salmon or the ancestors of salmon that
were spawning upriver out of the river
so like basically what grizzly bears do
because the salmon get up into this
shallow water where they're really easy
picking they're like congregating and
mass numbers and so for a predator it's
like a buffet that's all you can eat
buffet and those scorpions we're
probably taking advantage of that and
now they're fully terrestrial eyes along
with most other things and there are no
there's no us anymore so that's also
very interesting about evolutionary
biology is a study from 450 million
years ago the process of the terrestrial
ization yeah even of a creature to the
point where there's no more of them that
live in water right and there's some
cases they've like actually second that
really colonized water again like
spiders for example there's a group of
spiders that lives in water the diving
bell spider but basically you can see
all these like hints of ancestry from
from like their Anatomy of what their
ancestors used to be like like this is a
tarantula right
that's weird little model and I'm here
and in the tarantula there's this is
like a anatomical model which is maybe
like mostly accurate but the thing I
like about it is this part right here
this is the respiratory system this
green bit and as part of the respiratory
system it has these little things that
look like I don't know like a golf club
that's with a yellow end right here and
it would normally sit inside the body
and this part would be sitting up like
in a little pocket where it's exposed to
air so it's not outside of the body but
it's not like encapsulated in the body
either and what these are they're called
book gills or book lungs and it's
basically like a gill like you know a
fish Gill and you can see there's like
lots of little white lines that are the
gills and that's what helps them get the
oxygen yeah because it provides more
surface area and these these book lungs
are basically internalized gills so they
took all those little flaps that
increase surface area and pulled them
into their body and now they actually
have pages which is why it's called a
book lung because there's individual
pages and those pages help increase the
surface area so that they can breathe so
they actually just passively absorb air
from outside they absorb oxygen from air
that's passing over those book lungs
passively so they're not like breathing
in and out
they're just passively respiring okay so
there's no that's so interesting so
there's not really a the respiratory
system is not really a inhalation
exhalation it's possibly it's it's just
a there's no there's no inhalation
actually it's just a constant flow of
oxygen coming in slowly bit by bit yeah
they just have this book long in this
pocket that's exposed to the outside of
their body and that air comes in and it
flows over the pages of the book lung
that's basically an internalized Gill
and then oxygen diffuses into their body
which is actually one of the things that
limits their body size so people are
always like how big chemists can in Iraq
well they can only get it as big as the
oxygen can reach their tissues because
they have no active respiration yeah
yeah so then they're limited to the
above the biological mechanisms in size
they're actually limited to the chemical
mechanisms of how quickly oxygen can
diffuse into tissues in the cells yeah
you're interesting interesting but this
is about the largest tarantulas that
you'll get right I mean that one's
bigger than you would ever see a
tarantula in real life like the largest
tarantula and realize like two-thirds of
that size okay yeah yeah which is still
like pretty yeah that one's it's called
a Goliath birdeater and it's whether it
actually eats any birds but they live in
South America interesting so this
respiratory system is really interesting
now now was this part of the the system
desert it had nothing to do now but it
was one of the things that made me like
really intrigued with with scorpions as
a model system yes there's all these
telltale signs of their ancestors but my
dissertation was really focused on
understanding the evolution and
classification system of one group of
scorpions okay and they're called the
bark scorpion it's a bark scorpion
yeah and that bark scorpion like tell us
a bit about what you learned about it
well it's all it's not bark like a dog
it's bark like a tree yep because they
live typically they live in crevices and
often those crevices are like in a
desert Sonoran Desert yeah well the
Arizona bark scorpion lives in the
Sonoran Desert but they're actually
distributed from like they get all the
way up into like sort of middle America
middle United States and you can find
them all the way down and said northern
South America they're found in the
Galapagos they're found in all the
Caribbean islands Central America this
is pretty fairly common scorpion-like
appearance yeah yeah they're looking
scorpion they're called the Bark's court
yeah the bark scorpion then and I was
interested in this group because they're
one of the only groups of scorpions that
we have here in sort of northern America
so like Mexico in the u.s. that poses
any danger to humans why because they
have venom that's toxic to us so no I
think I asked you this before what
percentage of scorpions have venom
that's toxic it's really low so there
right now there's about twenty to twenty
four hundred species of scorpions that
have been discovered by scientists and
documented formally and of those about
two percent are dangerous toxic to
humans so well there's a higher
percentage that are toxic to humans but
there's one or two percent that are
dangerous t that are dangerous got it so
it's like 50 scorpion yes max 50 mass so
only 2400 ish have been classified
scorpion species interesting and so then
you went really hard into one species
for you yeah and part of the reason that
it's interesting it was interesting and
and also kind of a timely project is
that there's there's a lot of
pharmaceutical money that's invested
into developing anti-venom to combat
stings from the scorpions that's right
yeah we had a company vanilluxe on who's
an indie bio company that does a
therapeutic for scorpion yeah and it's
it's it's problematic when you're a
pharmaceutical company or biotechnology
company that's trying to develop
something to combat a sting but the
thing that is stinging in the first
place isn't properly described right
like we don't actually we weren't
actually really sure how many species
were posing a health problem it could
have been 10 it could have been five it
could have been three it could have been
20 but nobody had taken the time to
really redo the classification and tell
the rest of the world how you tell these
species apart yeah and so I thought that
that was saying it seemed like a good
project it had it had some impetus aside
from just classifying for classification
sake
which i think is also really important
but it's a very rare scorpion stings are
20,000 US cases a year yeah so the one
that we have that's potentially
dangerous in the United States is a
single species it's the Arizona bark
scorpion that lives in Arizona and lower
Nevada yeah and western New Mexico
Arizona bark score yeah and it's it's
not really date very dangerous
to adults like if you're a healthy adult
you don't have to worry about it oh whoa
the quarter there actually is really
important it helps them with scale a lot
yeah they're not very big they're a
couple inches at most now you brought
one of your adults these ones are little
babies those are so babies yeah they're
so small no you brought one of your
adults with you yeah I brought it
I brought the same scorpion that that I
had when we met awesome oh it's from
Malaysia so let's show let's show this
let's show this video quick this is
where this is you this is you going into
the field in Malaysia yeah and so this
is kind of and so but this is yeah so
but this is really this is you know this
is what it looks like when you go and do
literal field work like like this is you
right here in the field like this image
you know like in like this is really
interesting because you know here's you
with a headlamp with a with a what is
that tool called that that one that's
right there that that's called a leaf
litter sifter and it's just one of the
one of the tools that we employ to look
for arachnid recommends it turns out
don't really like being found
yeah that's we don't we haven't
discovered a lot of them yet and that
thing is is you take leaves and in the
middle of it there's like a screen like
with a yeah like maybe quarter inch grid
screen and you take leaves in there and
you you shake it up so that anything
that's smaller than a leaf will fall
through the screen down into the bottom
sleeve yeah and then we collect the all
the stuff that's fallen through the
bottom sleeve and like carefully look
through it to see what's in there
looking for spiders and mites which are
arachnids and scorpions and anything
that may have been hiding in the leaves
and and so that's the process of going
out into the field and sifting through
the again they don't want to be found so
you sift through it and then you can you
try and catch them and then you have to
see if you've classified them before so
you have to then like compare it to the
other 2,400 scorpion species to see if
they've been classified before and I
mean you can take some shortcuts like
you can just look at the ones that are
like live in Asia let's say okay right
so you don't have to look at the ones
that live in Oh the Americas pretty
unlikely to be those yeah but but yeah
you have to go through and like compare
them with what we know and try to figure
out if it's something we don't know yet
yeah there's relatively straightforward
but also kind of sometimes a kind of a
pain in the butt because it's not always
obvious like in the real olden days
right like in the earliest days of
people classifying animals classifying
life there wasn't like picture there
were no high-resolution photos there was
there was often times not even
illustrations and in scientific
publications because like that was too
costly to produce illustrations people
could just produce type and so the a lot
of the early descriptions were just like
a description sometimes in German
sometimes in Russian sometimes in French
yeah just the description instead of a
picture yeah no you can pull it up on
your phone and yeah make sure that it's
the right yeah we can like you know now
we have like microscope imaging so we
can actually take images through a
microscope of important characteristics
that help with identification and that's
like that's like normal that's standard
that you would include in this periscope
photo yeah this kind of description of a
new species when you discover a new
species include lots of pictures exactly
so back then you couldn't sleep that's
just a hundred years ago even yeah a
hundred years ago we weren't we weren't
taking thousands of pictures especially
microscope pictures of these and we
weren't you know able to to diagnose the
inside of the biology of the the
creature and then we could people were
doing dissections and like very manually
doing it all but one of the amazing
things that has been in place since the
earliest days of people classifying is
museums yeah and what that means is that
people were collecting stuff from nature
and bringing it back and putting it in
the museum yeah and then when they
discover this wrote about the this
description of a new species they would
also identify where it was like what
museum it was sitting in and that's
extremely helpful because what that
means for me is as much of a pain as it
is so like have to go to London and look
at the British Museum of Natural History
I can actually go and look at those same
scorpions that those people wrote about
their little description that they wrote
up yeah now now what is what is the
scorpion that you have what is it where
where does it classified as and what is
it living in right now to see you know
to survive it looks like dirty paper
it's living in dirty paper that's his
preferred habitat um so this is this is
a little scorpion that's lives in
Southeast Asia its scientific name is
like eelis Australasia eh what's the and
what would be the name that I would look
up to I don't know look up that one
fella
yeah it's Li o CH e le s and the other
name part of the name will probably come
up with it it did yep y ou Keeley's
Australia say what is let's see
wikipedia says it's the dwarf would
score food scores good to me
blind a family Hema scorpy idea yep it
belongs to one of the 13 families of
scorpions oh yeah oh yes so so what this
little guy this is a like I'll show you
closer in just a second but this little
guy is about adult size there are these
tiny little scorpions and where they
live in Southeast Asia's and tropical
rainforests like really humid like super
humid forests and they like to live in
rotting logs so when you said that he
was living in a dirty paper like that's
exactly right he's just living in this
wadded up piece of paper inside of yeah
like plastic jar and it's like really
wet and kind of like because they
basically like to something you got to
get used to when you do field work cause
you gotta get used to the sweaty smelly
sweaty and smelly is like the name of my
game of the game yeah exactly that
that's part of being a child is being
cool playing that's what I love about
being the field biologist is like it's I
get to just play outside outside yeah
and not be stuck in a cubicle behind the
desk yeah yeah so so this tiny guy it's
like about the size of my thumbnail
right he's he's harmless to humans he
has no toxins that affect our bodies
ronk do you get a good shot on it whoa
the way it just like moved it's yeah so
this really his only defense is like
hiding out or maybe like pinching with
his little tiny claws but that's about
his feels so cool this is a guy I
collected him in nature in Malaysia and
we're doing because he's actually not
quite an adult fully adult
so we've been cutting them up in our lab
plus he's kind of adorable
is it like a great scorpion ambassador a
great scorpion ambassador Wow doesn't
even look like he really has a head or
she you know yeah so scorpions kind of
one of the things about Iraq ones that
make them arachnids is they have two
main body parts a pro soma which is that
like a head and an epistle no just like
a body and this guy and smoked scorpions
a pro soma and missus oma are really
kind of fused like they look almost just
kind of like the head is a bigger plate
than the rest of the body weight at the
end it's not really a chuck it doesn't
really jut out yeah it's just like this
first part right here got it got it
yeah it doesn't like yeah it doesn't
shut out like a human's it's just more
part of the body
yeah so like this part right here this
is head but they kinda have a waist in
between their head in their body and
square means don't really have a waist
they just have like a head that's the
same width as their body and then their
tail at the end yeah and now now this
tiny guy there's like these are there's
lots of I mean these are so small
there's got to be lots of them that live
in these dirty log yeah environments
well when you find a log with them in it
like there's just hundreds of there's
hundreds of them they like to live like
kind of I don't know that it's
necessarily colonial II like they're not
socializing but they like to live in
these like clustered communities and
maybe that's just because the habitats
perfect like they're it's the perfect
law with the perfect witness and they
all just kind of move it
but yeah they're not rare when you see
them now why is this a good ambassador
because it's how he does no toxic venom
so you can handle them safely after the
kids have the kids play with it yeah
yeah exactly and that way kids don't
become scared of insects which is so
weird what's the deal with arachnophobia
you know I kind of wonder sometimes I
think I think arachnids well I'm gonna
say I'm gonna have to separate this into
components first spiders people are
scared of spiders it's like I'm 1/8
human fear to be scared of spiders and I
thought about it like so much because
it's like inevitably a question
everybody asks or like wants to talk to
me about their arachnophobia
let's scoop them back so that we can
keep focusing on convo what I think is
that arachnids move so so other than we
do like trying to smell the yeah like
people eat those people eat those around
the world it's like a little chunk of
protein it's like a chunk of protein
it's like a shrimp yeah that's yeah
that's nuts
yeah people eat those around the world
yeah in the u.s. we've gotten the West
to eat them by turning them into like
chips and granola bars and stuff we have
we've had chirps chips on the show which
really does that crickets crickets yeah
yeah but people do eat scorpions as well
especially in Southeast Asia it's like
they have like those you know those big
market places with like huge swathes
like in Southeast Asia and especially
countries and our protein moments it'll
eat any protein that's yeah
so please yes arachnophobia all right
yeah so I just think what they walk
really like utterly like they the way
that they move is in such a way that's
so unfamiliar to us it makes us like
feel fear the way they move it's like
like the eight legs like they're gay
we got the gig like like like take an
ant right and as an insect about six
legs and still move that weird like they
move in this very predictable way I
think I don't think people look at ants
and they're like oh that thing's moving
in such a creepy way but when they look
at spiders they feel that way oh you
think it's about the movement aren't
they a little like omnidirectional I
can't like they can just start going to
the side and then going forward and
going yeah like like most I would say
like most arachnids because of the
orientation of their legs they can
really move in lots of different
directions yeah and plus like I don't
know it's just like the order in which
their legs move is like weird one of the
media sorry it's yes well this Hollywood
propagation I don't think it's just
about the Hollywood propagation because
you also go to cultures where there's no
Hollywood
people are scared of spiders but not in
Southeast Asia right oh they are oh they
don't want to be around spiders okay
yeah but I would say with scorpions or
something different and like I think
spiders people oh my god it's a spider
like get it away smoosh it like kill it
immediately Oh people sea scorpions I
think they have this other reaction
where they're like oh that's really
terrifying because they they've heard
this but that scorpions are dangerous
like because of Hollywood because of the
media but they're also curious because
it's so like foreign they're like oh
what but let me see it close-up yeah I'm
scared of that but little closer look
yeah it's true right it's the Gateway
yeah ambassador the next thing you know
they're holding the scorpion oh oh it's
not dangerous it's not dangerous yeah
yeah wow it is so fun what is what's
over there what do you have in those two
jars those are also scorpions
so these are some specimens from our
collection at the academy whoa look at
that this is on the bigger side whoa
he's dead and would also make a good
ambassador but like you know even though
this guy is harmless because the toxins
that he produces in his
in his tail are not dangerous he he's
he's big and like if he did sing you it
would still hurt but it would be like a
thumbtack right it'd be like getting a
thumbtack jabbed in your hand like that
hurts it's just not dangerous
thumbtack jabbed in your hand yeah
that'd be how much it would hurt look at
the bottom of this you get a good let's
see if I can get it good Ron we're
getting I thought you were on that cam
but yeah this is yeah look at the bottom
of it this is this is very very very
beautiful so that that guy right there
is an impure peon Emperor school yeah
and they live in Africa and this one is
not the biggest specimen I've ever seen
by any stretch but they're the in terms
of weights they're the largest scorpions
okay by weight this is the largest you
see how huge their hands are like those
hands are heavy and they have this kind
of stout body that's also pretty pretty
weighty and they're big overall like
their overall size is quite large king
scorpions the emperor emperor now
doesn't what does an emperor scorpion
eat anything they can catch and mostly
that consists of like insects
mostly insects that are active at night
so like crickets cockroaches moths
things that are nighttime moving and
when the the Emperor or scorpions just
try and sting it first they would they
would actually just try to crush it with
their claws okay so they try and grab it
and crush it claws they're probably not
this kind of scorpion both the the one
that we just held that was alive yeah
the dwarf forest scorpion and the
emperor scorpion both of those would use
their claws as the predominant way of
capsule a subdued crown okay so claws
for capturing something and then what's
tell us about that one and this one here
it belongs to the other main category of
scorpions which is
means that subdued those things with
their tail and this is a belongs to a
family called booth Adi and booth Adi is
a group of scorpions that contains all
scorpions that are dangerous to humans
oh this is one of the dangerous yeah so
this one is actually called and rocked
enough and rottenness australis
Australis yeah yeah the fat fat tailed
scorpion and that guy can kill an adult
human this can kill an adult human yeah
so the Venom's toxic yeah and it'll kill
me in how long like do I have a good day
couple hours
yeah a few hours typically what happens
is the scorpion
would sing you the venom that it injects
is a like a mixture of multiple things
but one of the things that it's
injecting into you is a neurotoxin and
neuro Talk yeah and and what the
neurotoxin does is it targets your your
cells of your nerve cells in your body
and it either tells your nerve cells to
stop communicating so it inhibits
communication whoa or it activates
communication telling your nerve cells
to communicate like sending a signal
that something's happening but not
really it's just like tricking your body
yeah and what that thing that it wants
to convince your body is happening is
pain yeah because it's goal is to escape
because you are not a prey item you are
a predator predator yeah so it's you're
getting stung because you are predator
because you're perceived as a perceived
as a predator and it's trying to like
escape it like it's thinking that it's
in a life-or-death situation right like
it's it's staying or get eaten and it
stings and it causes your body to feel
pain even though nothing painful is
really happening like the stickers small
it's not really large enough to induce
extreme pain in your body but it's
telling your nerves to send a message to
your brain that you're experiencing pain
this is this is very very like you know
when you when you when you speak of
things like getting stung
and a neurotoxin hits it's scary
yeah so this is giza giza egypt is what
i read so you're reading the label on
them yeah so in every along with every
scientific specimen is a label that
tells when where and who collected it
this is 1959 mm-hmm so this is actually
a record like this is like a little time
machine that we're looking at right now
we are looking at a little time machine
yeah yeah it tells us what was happening
on earth at that place in time that's
right what is the liquid that is
suspended in it suspended in ethanol
which is like alcohol vodka yeah and
that's what we use as that's like this
the standard preservative fur for
arachnids and how do you use a how do
you get a how do you get the sheet of
paper and you print ink on it and then
you put it in there but it survives that
yeah we use ethanol insoluble ink that's
an all in soluble ink and same thing
paper insoluble well we just use
archival paper archival paper that's
what enables you to read like that yeah
but you know archival papers like what
you use like to back a piece of fine art
or it's very common wow this is nuts
that this is that this was found in
Egypt and it can has the neurotoxin
ability to Wow yeah you even have a
little like looks like a little like
skull and crossbones yeah yeah
interesting okay okay so that is nuts
now I have more questions for you my my
questions range everything from like
unpacking this in more nuance because
you're talking about the way that they
eat they you know they use the claws
first you to kill it smash the prey and
then eat that and then what else about
the survival of arachnids is quirky that
we should know that's like fun knowledge
well my one of my favorite facts about
scorpions is that they give birth to
live young
so they don't lay eggs they just like
straight up give birth like we do like
baby scorpions come out yeah yeah video
up of it on YouTube and it's cray-cray
it is it's kind of like what we do with
yes it's like comes out of her birth
canal exact exact and it breaks out of
the sack and it's like a live little
squirt it's out in the world no like not
I mean it's out in the world but it's
not on its own because part of it yes so
then that's strange because if this is
like 450 million years ago evolution
that I wonder did they ever lay eggs
it's we we have no evidence of them
laying eggs and there's even some
evidence that the ancestor of scorpions
which is this thing called a Europe to
rid okay a sea scorpion there's some
evidence that that your rip currents
also internalized they're young that's
Anna betta beware they gave birth or not
but but certainly like the ancestors of
scorpions at some point in time we're
laying eggs yeah but what I mean it's
really beneficial to life on land and
like to not legs like moving into new
areas of the of the world's to give
birth to live young because then all it
takes is one female right one female was
pregnant to make it to a new island that
has no scorpions on it and then suddenly
like start a new population of scorpions
in that place
Oh versus if if it needed to do eggs and
it couldn't versus have Athena to do
eggs you have to say near its offspring
where the eggs are laid right yeah like
like or say the eggs would have to make
it to a new place so you can be movable
with your offspring yeah Oh interesting
so the offspring either you'd lay an egg
and you'd have to stay around it or you
could bring it with you while it's
developing inside you and then go and
that that's kind of funny because that
takes us to the whole idea of like
whatever anchor babies and stuff like
that in different countries you can go
to a country while you're pregnant and
then have your child there and stuff
that's very interesting
so whoa the live the live
now i'm i'm so i'm so curious because
the how what you know we had this video
up we didn't we didn't end up getting
the show but that the male was like
rapping the female or what's the other
way around that spider yeah in a spider
bondage spider bondage well so the other
amazing thing about arachnids all
arachnid spiders scorpions is that they
all have courtship rituals of how they
made so yeah like they don't have this
like they don't like randomly just
deposit eggs and sperm and like me they
they actually like the males court the
females and every single case that we've
out that we know of
um and that happens in all kinds of
different ways and then this one example
that they were talking about earlier the
males of wolfs of this one species of
wolf spider they like find the female
and they're like half her size so it's
like dangerous territory when they
approach early she wants to so what what
they've done what they've like evolved
through time is that the males actually
like wrap the female's legs with silk
they call it spider bondage mmm-hmm it
probably doesn't prevent the female in
any way from eating him
really but that silk is probably very
laden in pheromones and chemical signals
telling her that he's a courting male so
it's probably like less about
restricting her movement and more about
like communicating to her as much as you
possibly can that you're according male
and she should not eat you like you are
of the same species and you're here for
a different kind of purpose yeah yeah
the the courting rituals yeah i'm always
trying to like anthropomorphize things
and be like I wonder how humans relate
to that yeah because we have our own
like quirky courtship rituals that yeah
it looks like that right but one of the
other things that like almost all
arachnids have to be able to do if there
Rockman's is be a good dancer like
they've got to have some moves and what
do they how do they do it depends like
scorpions they do a promenade to do so
they like face the female and hold hands
with her like a dance back and forth
like like ballroom dancing like this
together like he holds her toes are like
pools are backwards and lodges are
forward and like and they have sex in
the case of scorpions actually what they
do is he deposits this gelatinous oh
stalk called a spermatophore and it's
like just kind of looks like a triangle
like jelly yeah and then at the top of
it he puts a sperm packet what and then
they're still dancing while he does this
he has to do it at the same same time
that's multitasking and then he pulls
her over the gelatinous talk and if she
thinks this courtship was good she'll
like pick it like it inseminate herself
and if she didn't think it was good like
someone she'll eat it or she'll just
like leave it there this is so weird
oh my gosh yes because we're kids are so
different to what we know so dancing and
then I deposit this July on a stock with
sperm at the top yeah and then I pull
the female scorpion over it and then she
used to pick whether my courtship was
good enough and she can inseminate
herself or just eat it or leave it alone
yeah what a freaking crazy mating ritual
but it doesn't even in there because
then the females can actually decide
whether they want to store the sperm or
use it oh so she can either then like
use the sperm and actively inseminate
her eggs or fertilize her eggs or she
can just store in this little chamber
until she like decides it's a good time
of the year to get pregnant whoa whoa
which is interesting because then you
that they can wait a month couple months
potentially if it's four years they can
we whoa so they can almost like store
the sperm and then go and try and court
with other males to see you like
choose to use a different real sperm
yeah yeah and they could they can kind
of like rank the different courtships
until they find the right this guy's a
much better dancer I wonder what their
inventory is like can they hold like six
of them could they only hold one like
how large is their inventory like
observe scientifically observe courtship
so like in a you know a few dozen
species at the most I want to observe
courtship so if anyone wants to get
involved in observing biologics and
observing courtships
I think that would be a fantastic
profession what is it called it's called
the Elias lab okay and they take
high-speed video and record the songs
that spiders sing to their mates and the
dances that they do majors actually sing
yeah well it's it's really like a an
acoustic signal so it's transmitted
through the ground and then they have
ears in their feet that here whoa crazy
whoa yeah let's give more labs like that
please and they study jumping spiders
and jumping spiders do a coordinated
song and dance so they like make a sound
that's independent from the dance
they're made they're doing and there's
like the peacock was jumping spiders and
it has this beautiful on its what is
this called the bulb called the body the
body at the body it looks like a peacock
it was very beautiful
okay let's transition they're like the
birds of paradise of those spider or
birds of paradise world yeah they're
beautiful
and we'll let's let's finish up by
talking about science communication okay
so this is let's let's have dialogue
about it okay because here we were
talking about this at the beginning we
were explaining how if there were more
role models that were teaching children
that they could have the potential of
working in a field in like field biology
and
and whatnot that that that's how we get
more and more involvement in children in
these fields so what have been some of
the principles because we care so much
about science communication and
inspiring young people to build the
future would have been some of the cool
things that you've learned over time
about science communication that you
don't want to share I mean I think part
of part of the reason that I'm working
at a museum and particularly the
California Academy of Sciences is
because of the opportunities for science
communication for me personally I feel
like as a scientist especially a
scientist in an era where science this
question we have a personal
responsibility to communicate the
science that we're doing and not only
the science we do but the importance of
science in general so I never really
received any kind of training and how to
be a science communicator I think I've
just felt really passionately about it
and practice it a lot so that's that's
like number one thing like just practice
and passion and and I have I I would say
I have a policy and every my students
know that this is my policy and I'm very
vocal about it and that's that I say yes
to everything that I'm asked to do mm-hm
every opportunity for science
communication that I'm asked whether
that's talking to a kindergarten class
of seven people or like speaking in
front of 4,500 people I say yes mm-hmm
and that's because I think that we need
to get the message out there in every
venue that we possibly can about what we
do and why we do it and why it's
important to keep doing it and other
people should consider it as a career
yeah I don't think I've ever heard
anyone say that one of the principles of
their exam with science communication is
to always say yes because that then
opens up more and more Minds to the
field yeah that's that's cool also like
for me personally it opens up posit like
potential
yeah it's a lot of doors for me to say
yes yeah and I encourage my students to
say yes like obviously I don't want them
to say yes if it's adversely affecting
them and they're they're like lives and
their ability to get their work done as
scientists because first and foremost
that's what they have to do with
students but I think that it's important
to impress upon them that that we need
to communicate what we're doing and the
more practice you get communicating what
you're doing the better you get it
telling people the story that's right
I'm making them believe that it's
important because I think as a scientist
we all believe that what we're doing is
important otherwise we probably wouldn't
be doing it yeah and then what do you
think about the sort of we have this we
have a little bit of a there's like this
gap between the really prominent sort of
scientific researchers that are only in
their own fields in the very deep nuance
of their fields and then the general
public there's a huge gap so what do you
think about I mean I think we're trained
to have that gap like part of the
training of becoming a scientist of
getting a PhD is to become so
specialized and such higher-level
thinking and in the field that you're
studying that like you have a hard time
figuring out how to like step backwards
back down the ladder to tell the normal
person what you're doing and I think
that there's a lot of ways that you can
think through how to communicate like
your elevator pitch right like how to
communicate what you're doing to an
ordinary person and I would say that
more than ever we need to figure out how
to do that
yeah because people like aren't
believing in science anymore which is
horrible mm-hmm but a good place to
start is just like in your own personal
life so even if you don't have time to
go out and speak publicly or you don't
have an inclination to go out and speak
publicly because you have a fear of
public speaking or you know whatever
personal and
you have you all you do have
relationships with other human beings
and most like some of those people are
not scientists
and if you can get them to understand
what you're doing is why it's important
and you can explain to anybody yeah I
like tell you you're really you know it
seems as though you're very you have a
very strong you're a strong emotional
tie to this and and I do too I think I
think I think civilization as we embody
science and as we embody figuring out
how to collect if we progress together I
think we'll be able to prosper better
and I and I totally agree with the 30
second elevator pitch we talk about that
to entrepreneurs all the time we're like
I get your 30 second pitch down get your
30 second pitch down ask powerful
questions ask powerful questions and so
when you can when you can really get
someone inspired about about biology or
evolution really quickly I think that
can be a big light for people that you
know you can just like you were saying
at the beginning you're flipping over
some bricks and you're looking at what's
underneath of them some stones and just
seeing what creatures live under there
all right
last last couple of questions that we
like to ask on the show do you think
we're in a simulation I don't know I
think about it they like kind of freaks
me out so I have to stop myself but like
I'm gonna I'm just gonna like hope that
we're not because if it is like I feel
like something's going wrong with the
simulation right now and it's like
spiraling out of control the challenge
but experiments if humans can persevere
through the challenge I mean in some
ways like evolution is a simulation
right yeah it's all a bunch of variables
and being computed right now I'm
thinking like inevitably humans are
gonna go extinct like that's inevitable
in the evolutionary scale of time we can
digitize our consciousness we could but
then who will care okay who cares now
yeah yeah okay how about are we alone in
the cosmos yeah the probability of that
is so low
the there has to be other other beings
whether they're conscious beings or not
is not for me to determine but like the
probability of other of other life I'll
even go as far as to say other
carbon-based life being in the cosmos is
high yeah and then what do you think
that looks like oh no I hope it looks
like a bunch of like giant you wall is
because there yeah yeah yeah you have a
you had it for 17 years
yeah this is your bias towards wadding
civilizations of Chihuahua tell you
exactly a thousand of them at the same
time like just like like they look like
Taco Bell's you all okay yeah okay last
question is what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world
oh I think that the most beautiful thing
in the world is like real nature and
that's really hard to find like I'm on
the human mediated nature it basically
doesn't exist anymore I mean humans have
been around for a very very long time
changing our ecosystems like way before
like the Agricultural Revolution or the
tech revolution or anything else totally
and so we've been changing those
landscapes forever and there's very few
landscapes that we haven't touched and
when you see those it's like really a
thing of beauty nature and the history
of evolution of life on Earth has
created some magical stuff that was such
a good answer and I don't think we've
had that exact answer yet we've had like
the most beautiful thing is that it's
it's earth without the humans or
something like that but that's like the
closest we've gotten and I think we've
talked on the show a lot about what were
the feelings that were felt in humans
that first made it to land that was
unexplored and that that is such a
profound feeling and you talk about the
beauty of that land and I think that's
what really gets us wanting to birth out
of the womb
earth is to be able to go and look at
what those other unexplored territories
look like and also make these virtual
worlds where we can then synthesize what
it would be like to go and find new land
it's just yeah it's exhilarating and
it's gorgeous and you can have thousand
200 civilizations with waterfalls and
star systems and that's what the Aztecs
were offering I'm those such as those
such a good answer
Lauren this has been such a pleasure
this is look at all this cool stuff that
we learned about today and thank you for
coming on to the show thank you we
really appreciate it thank you thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it give us your thoughts in
the comments below we'd love to hear
from you go and build the future go and
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone much love and join us join us
in the movement hit that subscribe
button below also join us if you want to
see a scale our content impact more
people we have plenty of positions that
we want to hire for chop these clips up
from 60 minutes down into one minute
segments and circulate those join us
patreon is below cryptocurrencies below
join us across those platforms Twitter
Instagram you can find us everywhere
much love and we'll see you soon